sylvie chaillou présidente de textile du
maine bonsoir sylvie chaillot merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
l'industrie textile sous l'impulsion du
gouvernement s'est mobilisé c'est votre
cas n'est ce pas au textile du maine que
vous êtes dans quelle situation
aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui nous avons interrompu
notre fabrication de masques nous étions
42 entreprise à s'être associés pour
produire massivement des masques on ne
la produit près de 2 millions est
aujourd'hui la demande est pratiquement
à l'arrêt on doit vendre moins de quatre
mille masques par jour alors qu'on en a
vendu jusqu'à 100 milles par jour
alors depuis la mi mars environ 450
entreprises françaises se sont convertis
alors fabrication a parfois au prix
d'investissements supplémentaires
comment justement vous allez
rentabiliser ses investissements alors
une bon nous nous sommes sûrement une
corporation nous sommes des
confectionneurs et des maroquiniers donc
des machines à coudre des machines de
coupe nous avions nous disposions des
outils des outils nécessaires pour
fabriquer des masques donc nous on n'a
pas eu de soucis de d'investissement
mais je sais que il y a des collègues
notamment textiliens qui ont énormément
investi pour acheter du matériel de
fabrication et aujourd'hui ils sont en
grande difficulté puisque on ne peut
plus écouler on ne peut plus cool et nos
masques et on a les frais qui sont là
alors une réunion s'est tenue à bercy
aujourd'hui entre justement les
fabricants français de masse grand
public en tissu et la secrétaire d'état
le gouvernement qui vient de lancer une
mission de promotion du made in france
c'est à dire aussi pousser les
entreprises à utiliser les masques en
tissu lavable plutôt que c'est ces
masques chirurgicaux qui nous viennent
souvent de chine - écologique et moins
économique c'est un début de solution
pour vous de toute façon ça toujours été
le discours de la ministre madame
manière une hache et son souhait c'était
effectivement que l'on fabrique des
masques avec des normes françaises et
et que et que ce soit des masques
réutilisables ça faisait partie du
projet malheureusement au moment du des
confirmands et je pense qu'il ya une
grande panique de la part de beaucoup
d'acteurs qui ont importé massivement
des masques d'ailleurs et ce sont des
masques chirurgicaux pour moi masques
chirurgicaux sont des masques qui
doivent être portés par des soignants et
donc les masques qu'on nous a demandé de
fabriquer c'est vraiment des masques
destinés à protéger les gens qui
travaillent et les gens pour leur vie
quotidienne
aujourd'hui vous sortez de cette
expérience dans quel état d'esprit une
forme d'amertume parce que c'est vrai
qu'on vous a sollicité on le disait
aujourd'hui voilà vous avez du mal à
écouler vostok c'est c'est sûr que c'est
une situation compliquée dans notre
groupe on en fait on a six cent trente
mille euros d'investir afin de stocker
plus chaud aujourd'hui invendus donc
forcément on a pris un gros risque est
élevé pas comment se sortir de vraiment
de cette situation on va pas espérer
qu'il ya une seconde balle pour espérer
écouler nos produits donc on est
vraiment dans une impasse et il va bien
falloir que que les personnes qui nous
ont demandé de ceux de nous mettre cette
activité nous aide à nous en sortir
aujourd'hui clairement vous vous
retournez sylvie chaillou vers le
gouvernement vous ont appelé à leur
responsabilité donc il ya deux personnes
qui ont été missionnés deux personnes de
la filière qui ont été missionnés pour
faire une étude
donc ces deux personnes vont réfléchir
aux solutions éventuelles que l'on a
écoulé nomas volées proposé après au
ministère et ce sera au ministère
d'arbitré mais de toute façon on ne peut
pas on a mis nos tripes sur la table du
jour au lendemain et du fabricant de
masques alors que c'était pas du tout
notre activité on a répondu à un effort
de côme gallet le président c'est un
effort de guerre donc aujourd'hui on
peut pas nous lâcher on a répondu au
pays
aujourd'hui il faut assurer il faut
assumer merci beaucoup sylvie chaillou
président de textile
dumaine d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france